okay we're all good good evening members
uh and officers uh thank you for joining
us everybody welcome to this meeting of
the overview and scrutiny panel on the
17th of february
2022. thank you all for coming
if the fire alarm procedures are
activated please vacate the offices down
the main staircase opposite the lifts in
the foyer and assemble on hawley square
on the green and officers will assist us
back into the building when it's deemed
safe for us to return would everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they're
not used to make or receive phone calls
whilst this meeting is in progress i'm
always tempted there to say text
messages whatsapps linkedins and all the
rest of it as well
because they still go off but if we can
make sure the phones are on flight mode
or something or switched off
this meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public and it will also
be recorded and will subsequently be
broadcast on the internet i can't see
any members of the public with us this
evening but does anybody else here
intend to film the proceedings
okay we will rely on the main
filming
and there's no need for me to ask the
same
question of the public speaking under
rule 20.1 do any members have any
speeches they'd like to make under 20.1
okay and i haven't received any requests
for public speaking
either
so moving on to the main substance of
our agenda then uh apologies for absence
i've had apologies from councillor keith
coleman cook forgive me with these
glasses i can see that but not you i've
got colored blobs is is there anybody
anybody missing
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve i don't think
there are so it's just keith um
so we make a note of that are there any
declarations of interest on our gender
items this evening members
uh then we move on to the minutes of the
overview and scrutiny panel meeting held
on the 18th of january
uh members can i have a proposal to
propose these minutes please thank you
councillor moore
and the second to please thank you
councillor
and do members agree
thank you very much
we now come to the first of our two
presentations this evening i'd like to
invite councillor
jill bayford to introduce the item for
us and i believe she's going to be
handing over to richard
jill
thank you chair
um
yes i have an easy ride tonight i think
um i'd like to introduce
richard hopkins who is our private
sector housing manager and has for you
tonight a detailed and i think very
interesting presentation
about
private housing in the district and how
the council regulates surprising how
private housing in planet thank you
richard
uh i stand up so i can see everybody had
that
mind uh can anybody hear me do you want
to put your mind
yeah okay i usually got a
fairly loud voice
right uh yes so i've been asked to give
an overview of uh private sector housing
in planet and how we regulate it so what
i've done is done a presentation where
i've gone through the team it's set up
what we do and how we go about stuff and
the main gist of uh of what we do and
there's some some facts and figures in
there as well that hopefully gives you
an idea of where we're at so um
i thought i'd start with some um
some stats on
the private sector in thanat just to
give you some context
so according to the english house survey
in england there's about 19 privately
rented in most uh most
as an average across the country
um
it's been about 19
for quite a few years now about four or
five years
um and so i broke it down by ward
unfortunately the data is a little bit
old it's the census data because that's
the most reliable data and we are
looking forward to some data coming out
in april may this year which will update
this
for last year's census but you can see
that um cliftonville west has 56
privately rented uh which is quite
significantly higher than 19
we've got 51 at margaret central
central harbor's 40 and east cliff is 39
and i think we go down to about viking
which is
just
over a third of the way down is where we
get to the uh average uh 19 so we have
um
two areas mainly margate central area of
the town and ramsgate town centre there
where they're particularly high compared
to the national average
so
we
have a duty to review our stock and do
some some
general review
analysis
so
we do that every sort of five six years
something like that
2002 2008 we
surveyed 100 properties and then
extrapolated the data
and then more recently all local
authorities are going to modeling based
on information that local authorities
and other organizations have
and you can see that in 2002 we had
about 9 800 and something privately
rented properties and uh the estimate in
2017 is now at 17 000. so it has gone up
a lot
and that reflects where we are across
the country where from about 2 000 um
to about now the private rented sector
has doubled in size
so privacy to housing that sits within
the housing and planning
directorate
service so i sit alongside housing
options
housing strategy and projects tenant
leasehold services council property and
also of our colleagues in planning
and so my team is divided uh currently
into four areas uh we have a housing
improvement team
housing licensing team empty homes team
and a slightly different colored cold
homes team because that's a
short-term project which we'll
briefly talk about so the housing
improvement team is a statutory function
we have a duty as a local housing
authority to respond to complaints of
housing disrepair across our district so
if someone
has got a problem their landlord's not
fixing their boiler or there's damper
mold or something like that we have to
respond
and that is something that the housing
improvement team
does for us
we've got a housing licensing team also
a statutory function because we have
the licensing of houses in multiple
occupations like your bed sits and
shared houses and the like
and uh we have to license all of those
if there are five or more people and
they're sharing
so
and of course selective licensing which
i'll come on to in a bit more detail a
bit later
the empty property team also
a non-statutory service but
vitally important because obviously we
need to try and avoid empty homes where
we can
so the cold homes team
is effectively an enhancement of a
statutory function that we have
and that's to enforce what is known as
the meis regulation which is the minimum
minimum energy efficiency standard
so new rules have come into place over
the last few years where um
every single rented property must meet a
minimum standard uh according to an
energy performance certificate
so uh the core teams are
in the improvement license in an empty
home team the cold homes team
is fully funded by bays
which is the department of business
energy and industrial strategy i can
never remember that
and so we received 76 000 pounds
for uh for a seven month project
so that's really good so that
really boosts our enforcement capacity
uh in general uh thanit has been
exceptionally successful in recent years
and has almost been
successful in every guide application
it's made for additional resources to
expand our team
so for example
we have had a rogue landlord team
for a number of years and
we were given over half a million pounds
to fund that uh from
from the government and at that time we
were the
first local authority in the whole
southeast region to be awarded anything
from that particular government pot
and obviously they like what we're doing
because they gave us another quarter of
a million uh shortly thereafter
so i've talked about the legal duty
we've the housing improvement team has
one senior
four officers and an assistant
on average
we have around 900 complaints from
members of the public each year to deal
with so over the last five five years
it's
nearly four and a half thousand
uh how do we deal with that well um if
it's really urgent uh we call it high
priority and we get out as soon as
possible we're not a blue light service
of course because we don't have
um we can't do things really immediately
everything takes a little bit of time
and ultimately it's not our
responsibility for most stuff
it's the landlord
priority where we always get to
you within 10 days but we try and do it
quicker if possible
and then we have where the bulk of the
stuff which is not
particularly urgent but definitely needs
looking at and that depends on service
demand but we have a service
standard or within 10 weeks but we try
and keep it
no more in a month if we can
so just a couple of pictures to give you
a little bit of a
scenery as such so
that was someone's ceiling in their
living room
that was a uh
someone's bedroom and they were living
in that property
actually that was quite scary because uh
one of my officers went there and they
were with matt all right from housing
enforcers and the television crew they
didn't know what to do so they called
called me in um
so well good when it's normal but when
you've got cameras in your face and you
decide on something quite serious it was
a challenge but uh
yes that's uh that was on tell you that
one
that one was a young lad 18 years old
living in a bed
ceiling collapsed windows broken and
that was his bed
broken sockets kids in that room you
could tap the live terminal which could
kill you kill anyone to be honest
this one was common parts of an hmo
children living upstairs anybody could
have fallen off that and gone down and
given themselves the right mischief and
something quite serious potentially
so there's lots of lots of lots of uh
disrepair for us to deal with
so i was asked how we regulate so i've
just briefly mentioned that
the housing health and safety rating
system is the main government prescribed
way of assessing housing conditions
um you know
any any dwelling should be safe for
visitors or occupiers
it's based on a whole house assessment
there are 29 hazards for us to to look
at and assess
uh and you get a score and then it turns
out with abandon it's a bit more
complicated than it needs to be
but essentially you end up with a
category one hazard or a category two
hazard if it's a category one then we
have a duty to take action one of the
prescribed forms
if it's a category two then we have a
power which is more discretionary
so
the hhs first is a way of assessing
property but it doesn't necessarily tell
you what you should do at the end of it
it just assesses the seriousness
of the issue
i won't dwell on this too long but there
are the 29 hazards
i would say the
most common is excess cold
some of the falling hazards electrical
hazards
fire safety
um entry by intruders
um
yeah structural collapse and full
elements is quite a common one as well
no
hot water or heating is is a common
thing that comes under excess cold and
personal hygiene for not having hot
water for bars and showers and things
like that
so
how do we enforce all this well uh it's
obviously best if a landlord can um
just get on and do it we could find them
up and they get undo it
that is the ideal situation sometimes it
happens quite often it doesn't but it is
the quickest way of achieving
a good outcome
if
we're in a situation where we've got to
take action the most common
types of enforcement action are
improvement notice hazard awareness
notice prohibition order
emergency prohibition order and
emergency remedial action where we can
go in and
do those works ourselves and recharge
the landlord
which we did we did recently and it was
appealed against and we won
and we actually won cost which is which
is unusual on a tribunal
but the most common thing that we do is
an improvement notice because that's
what gets property into a better
condition than it was before
so i
chair the
kent housing technical group
and a colleague of mine who's just
become a new manager
somewhere else in ken asked me to do
some benchmarking
and asked me to ask all the local
authorities in kent how many improvement
notices they serve per
financial year so
these were the results um
i quite like this slide to be honest um
but i think
you know
every district every district is
different
uh but it did reassure me that my team
are doing doing quite well i think uh in
the circumstances
um
this is a bit of a busy slide
um
the main reason putting this on is that
we don't just use the house net 2004
which most this comes under there's
loads different legislation and um
the authority
here is
is very um proactive and if if there's a
piece of legislation that we can use to
make someone's life better we'll use it
um
there has been a lot of increased
regulation in recent years that we've
had to
to take on um
and some of it's quite burdensome um so
we have to make sure that all letting
agents uh
are signed up for address scheme we
there's there's new smoke and carbon
monoxide regulations
uh energy efficiency which come on later
and one of the big ones uh well big two
is electrical safety regulations where
every
um rented property now has to have
electrical certificate bit like the gas
certificate situation
and financial penalties which come on
into a bit
in addition to the housing conditions
side of things we also
a few years ago took over the
uh the duty of dealing with uh unlawful
eviction and harassment
uh it's exceptionally uh uh challenging
in itself because
most of our work is professional officer
goes along sees a problem serves notice
goes back hasn't been done as an offense
quite easy
this is this person said that person
said it's more like a police
investigation it's
it's quite hard
but we we've put a lot of effort into in
the last few years and
i just put up a little case study
about someone
funnily enough it was one of our our
projects we would written to this
landlord said
you've got a substandard property the
energy efficiency needs to be improved
please go and improve it um
he took uh the starts of
there was a couple and the couple and
and the lady was pregnant and asked him
to move out temporarily while he did
those repairs he moved him himself and
never let them come back
which uh
and they were safer surfing for a long
time
uh and obviously not enough just before
um giving birth which wasn't an ideal
situation so we prosecuted um uh
it was very close
for prison um because that they they
wanted a
another hearing for sentencing and he
just about got away with it however he
did have to pay our prosecution costs
and
um had to do 160 hours in the community
unpaid and we assisted the tenants to
get a rent repayment order
uh which was given in the sum of six
thousand pounds so those tenants got six
thousand pounds and landlords got to pay
that
um
i'll dwell a few on a few slides because
one of the big things is
usually
um in the past
you if an offence was committed uh by a
landlord we would prosecute
a couple of years ago a change in
legislation we have the ability to do
financial penalties now and there are
certain offences
such as non-compliance of an improvement
not licensed in an hmo and a few other
things as you can see there that we
could issue a financial penalty for
um there's a statutory maximum of 30 000
pounds so it's quite a significant
figure
but we can't do both so once we've
decided which route we're going to do
we've got we've got to go with one of
them we can't
we can't flip flop across we have to go
with one
um
a financial penalty that has to be the
same level in terms of the criminal
standard of
but you know one of the obviously the
differences here the prosecution fines
i mean we prosecuted a little while back
got a 20 000 pounds fine
but that obviously stays with the
justice system goes back to the treasury
somehow
um with financial penalties
um we get to keep the money and it's
ring fence to private sector housing
enforcement activities so it's it's a
sort of uh
government sort of push to
to push local authorities to have
the ability to put more resources in and
do more enforcement make more homes safe
so how do we issue financial penalties
because we're essentially the court you
know we're we're making that decision
aren't you guilty or not
and once we have then we
look at what the penalties should be and
we look at culpability their track
record
their portfolio size
so bigger landlords should know better
to be honest and smaller landlords may
be
maybe
you know should know better but might be
less informed
and then with risk of harm so dependent
on how serious the problem was that
we're dealing with
so we have a table it's got 192
figures on it lots of them and it goes
from a thousand pounds up to 30 000
pounds
um
like the court system we can
deal with mitigating and aggravating
circumstances
so we do go down to about 500 pounds to
the up to 30 000 pounds so we we
sort of
maximize it if it's appropriate and we
do offer a
a bit of a reduction if they pay quickly
um
so
if financial penalties are not paid this
is where it gets more honest for the
council because before it's up to the
court system to get their fines nothing
to do with us but here
we have to do that
a certificate signed by our chief
finance officer
to say that their penalty penalty hasn't
been paid is conclusive evidence of that
fact
and there are various things you know
the
normal civil debt type situation
bailiffs order south attachment to
earnings and the like
so where we got to um
so our policy came into effect in 2019
we've served 52 financial penalties
uh well 52 are subject to a notice of
intent because there's two stages to it
uh we've issued 24 uh final notices uh
five are subject to appeal at the
present time
uh we've entosed in imposed 196
500 pounds worth of
uh penalties three have been withdrawn
because
uh
a gentleman died in in that process and
another limited company was wound up and
ceased to exist
we've got 24 another sorry 25 pending a
decision
we've received only about 20 000 pounds
so far but we are
dealing with that with our debt recovery
team and recovery procedures
are in play
and just to say that if we're aware of
the property um you know there may be
the option to put a charging order on
their uh property to try and secure
those debts
against them
uh licensing team so second uh team
we've got um
was a lot larger when our selective
licensing scheme was going
and the designation was in place
but that has shrunk down now obviously
and now we've got two 2.6 officers so
two two officers and a part-time officer
and they do
hmo licensing selective licensing we do
a little bit of caravans which i
mentioned a bit later and we do landlord
engagement
so this was introduced in 2006 licensing
of
hmos um
designed to
improve
the management standards and conditions
in the higher risk ones
so if an hmo has five or more people
and they're two or more households and
there's some sharing or
non-self-containment involved then you
have to get a license from the council
and um
and if you don't it's an offence um
uh up until 2018
it had also had to be three stories or
above but now they've included one and
two stories
at the present time uh we have about 70
hmos licensed of that size in thanet
when the new rules come into place lots
of hmos decided to drop from five or six
to
four
to avoid the licensing regime so you'll
find there's lots of four person
hmos around
license conditions there are some that
are mandatory some of the discretionary
that we can add if we want um
and
we we've added as much as we can
reasonably to ensure that an hmo is
appropriately managed and it's things
like gas safety fire safety all the
things you you could imagine waste
management
asb making sure that the landlord takes
responsibility from for the behavior of
some of their tenants not actually the
behavior but responsibility of trying to
deal with it should it arise
and all and of course
to prevent overcrowding we have
occupancy restrictions
uh selective licensing so
we've had two phases of selective
licensing
which ran to 2006 phase one then we went
back to back and then we had another
phase that ended last year
selective licensing
is an extension of
licensing in as much as
if you designate an area
then anything inside the area if it's
rented it needs a license from the
council
the conditions are not quite as onerous
as hmos but they're pretty wide ranging
and you can do quite a lot to make sure
that landlords take their
responsibilities quite seriously
so
you had specific reasons for designated
selective license in the last
designation we talked we wanted
improvement in the social and economic
conditions
reduction in asb
and crime and improvement in housing
conditions and
an improvement in deprivation
so that was the last designation which
sort of run from trinity square through
to
warwick road
and bounded by uh north down road
so just to see that in um
in context of the rest of planet it was
sort of about half the ward of
cliftonville west and about a quarter of
fifa margate central
so the designation has expired so we're
not actually asking for new applications
at the moment
but all existing licenses
are still valid until they expire and
they usually have a five-year license so
you know
arguably all the landlords that were
compliant and applied straight away at
the early part of the scheme they had a
five-year license and they're beginning
to expire now
those are a bit more reluctant to
license and license later in the scheme
they'll have probably quite have a few
more years left of being subject to
additional regulation
so we have about uh 1400 or so still
licensed at the moment
inspection's ongoing we can take
enforcement action if necessary
and we talked about conditions a moment
ago so here's just a few figures i've
plucked out
um
we've over the over the period we've had
2 800 license applications and some of
those licenses
applications can apply to more than one
property if the if it's a free elder who
owns all the flats in the building so we
had i think the highest number that came
under one license was 29 but it's quite
common to have four five six dwellings
under a license
um
at one stage or another we had about
fifteen hundred allegations of
unlicensed premises operating illegally
and we did those investigations that
eventually resulted in about thirteen
hundred applications
we fully inspected over two thousand uh
properties
we've issued nearly two thousand four
hundred
licensed conditioned breach warnings
because we've had to identify something
that's not quite right
and in that time in the area the
selective licensing area
we've served 652 enforcement notices on
landlords to improve their properties
um
you know we also apart from our
proactive work we had 2099
complaints that we we resolved
uh in terms of enforcement um
obviously lots of notices but you know
most of it was complied with eventually
um but we we did do 48
uh prosecutions specifically on the
selective licensing
legislation and imposed 20 financial
penalties
so what are we doing at the moment we're
currently exploring
further opportunities
and at the moment
[Music]
the central focus is on the center of
ramsgate and the center of
mar gate
one of the the key ones that we're
looking for is deprivation at the moment
most likely and this is a deprivation
mapper and you can see that bright red
um is the most deprived areas and
some of the other ones you can see
outside the towns
quite
uh they sort of relate quite closely to
um
to some council housing estates and of
course they fall outside our remit
um so we are looking primarily at the
towns
um at one stage
and that's improved we
improved that
um
out of 32 844 areas defined by the
government in terms of deprivation one
being the worst
and 32 144 being the best
we had number four in cliftonville and
that's across the entire country
so as you can imagine um you know we've
done a lot of that that's actually moved
up in the last edition of the
government's data which is really good
so we go we did sort of fall down a
number of years but now
things are are back on the up but
there's still more work to be done
sorry to interrupt you richard um just
while you've got the map up it's easier
to refer yeah yeah well it's up um
the
obviously it gives a general picture
but for example the ward of northwood
you can split neatly in half between
quite
comfortably often well-to-do
areas and those where you would imagine
the deprivation
is
but on a map like that the whole of
northwood goes down as an area
um
within 10 percent of the most deprived
in england
um
yeah so yeah
i mean um
what you can't quite see on that because
it's obviously quite a
zoomed out map but actually the
deprivation is is based on what's called
lower layer super output areas
and they're very peculiar areas they go
um they apply to an area where about
1500 people live so each ward is
actually broke up
two three four different lower layers
so you can identify
which areas specifically are the most
deprived so in some wards
you will see um
uh some you know lighter colors uh with
a lower layer super helpful it's a bit
different
um but but yeah when you zoom in you'll
be ab you can see the specific areas
that are more challenging
numbers of people within that area
so the way they've done it to make it
comparable is created an area that's
specifically of the same size across the
entire country
so they do actually change from time to
time because those are you know
population new builds and all this sort
of thing
yeah
uh
all right yeah so we we recently took
over um
a little bit of work from environmental
health they deal with holiday site
caravans
and a few years ago the government
introduced lots more legislation
specifically aimed at ones that are um
occupied on a permanent basis by
someone's home
uh so we've got three sites in than it
has about 207 units and site licensing
is is more about the site it's not
really about what's inside the caravan
it's about the services the widths of
road can a fire engine get up there and
are they are they close too close or too
you know
too close to boundaries and stuff like
that so there's conditions on licensing
so we've recently picked that up and
have started looking at those sites
that's something else that the licensing
team does
landlord engagement of course it's not
all just about enforcement you know we
want to educate encourage and get people
to do the right thing it's really really
important so
we actually created a landlord focus
group for fanet
we we have a chair that is actually a
landlord or an agent and there's about
15 16 members at the moment
they meet two or three times a year
you know and we can bounce ideas off of
them for policy and they can come to us
with emerging issues we also hold an
annual event uh each year to tell
landlords about new things coming up or
what's going on and they usually help um
there's usually about 50 to 100
landlords that come along to that so
that's quite good
we also collaborate
with atlas which is an organization that
works across london and some of
the regions
to create a landlord accreditation
scheme and through that there are 632
landlords or agents with property and
senate that are accredited and they have
to do a training course and sign up to a
code of conduct
so the cold homes team which is the
temporary one the one we got some money
for is paid for entirely by uh by the
government department base
and it's about ensuring that rented
property has a minimum energy efficiency
standard of
e
and anything that is an f or a g is
considered to be a substandard property
so
epcs are required when a property is
built sold or rented and they last for
10 years and if it's valid and it's an
frig then it shouldn't be left
it doesn't extinguish tenancies uh that
are currently in place um but it
certainly um stops people renting them
and if you know we find out which we do
because we are gone through everything
um then we will be taking action so
if a landlord has a property with an
frig
rating there are some statutory
exemptions and if they have they have
have to register it on what's called the
prs exemption register government
website that we have to check and
enforce
and the prs means private rented sector
so uh if you don't comply with the mies
ban there are
differing
financial penalties again
two thousand four thousand one thousand
two thousand non-compliance of notices
false or misleading information on the
register and the time that you have
uh let the property uh unlawfully um
at the moment though the maximum you can
be fined for
letting a prohibited property is five
thousand pounds per tenancy
so what we've done so far since uh since
september when we started well we had a
cold homes project funded by another
government department a couple of years
ago and that ended up with 299
substandard properties
by the time we started this project with
the new funding that was a year later so
we
we had done some enforcement during that
year as well
uh
we we come down to 198 so we we found 26
new ones and 100 and something
had been improved
so what we've done uh since then is
we've served 173 compliance notices uh
which relate to 132 homes because some
properties are owned by more than one
person
we've received 82 responses
we've improved 48 homes so people are
living in much
better property as it stands um we've
got 44 reminder letters been sent out
and now we're in the last six weeks and
that phase is penalty notices so penalty
notice will start to be issued shortly
and we still have 180 18 homes that
remain substandard but we will pursue
those as best we can
there are some changes ahead i just
thought i'd add this in because the
government are considering increasing
the minimum standard to a c which is
quite a significant jump
um for new tenancies from 25 and
existing tenancies from 2028
is also an increasing cost cap because
at the moment landlords if it costs more
than three and a half thousand pounds to
improve they can get an exemption which
you know it doesn't appear to be a very
high amount of money and they're
actually thinking of changing it to ten
thousand pounds
uh they're also thinking of
of increasing the penalty to 30 000
pounds pretty much like what the
financial penalties for the stuff i
mentioned earlier but they haven't uh
responded to the consultation yet but
that is something in the pipeline
and just for completion uh for the
fourth team we've got empty homes i have
bought uh mentioned this uh overview
scrutiny not that long ago so just a
couple of slides
uh obviously they're not great we don't
want them we got we're desperate for
housing and they can cause real problems
in the neighborhoods
government use council tax data every
october to decide how many empty homes
there are so as of last october there
was 877
and when we talk about long-term empty
homes we talk about ones that have been
empty for six months or more
we adopted a an empty property plan in
2020 uh to give a flavor of all the
things we're doing and we're trying to
to achieve
we've got
a team of two officers an empty homes
officer and a support officer
current caseload they have 732
properties they're monitoring and trying
to do their best
to get back into use although it should
be noted that empty homes it's not
unlawful to own an empty home so
dealing with them is a little bit needs
to be a bit more creative
um informal advice and encouragement is
the key one that we use to get
empty hours back into use but we also
collaborate with kent county council
with interest-free loans
and of course enforcement action where
it's appropriate if it's affecting next
door or it's a real ice or something
like that
so
we try to tackle all of those on our
list but we do prioritize for
more
advanced enforcement action where it's
possible
and we got four bands so we've got 48 in
the highest 122
in b and those are the two areas we
focus most of our energies on but
doesn't mean that we don't look at the
others and try our best where we can
so
kent county council collects data to say
how many empty homes have been brought
back into use with the help of some form
of council intervention and of the last
i think it's 13 of the last 16 years
we've uh we've we've achieved the most
as a local authority in kent
and you can see that um
we're still
pretty much there
and for this year we're 139 as of
december so we're on target to um
to get to our uh
increased target based on our empty
homes plan of 170
and lastly
you'll be pleased to know
is that we work collaboratively with kcc
because they have a large recyclable
fund of money for empty homes and can be
used as interest-free
and because we work very closely with
them you can see over the years since
that scheme has been in place that we as
a local authority have managed to bring
back into use 33 of all the homes that
have been by that uh scheme
and so about 14 well nearly not quite
not quite but you know 13.8 million
pounds has been loaned
uh encouraging 14.8 million of a million
of other uh investment totaling 28
million and you can see 418 home has
been brought back into use through our
collaborations
um
so that's it hopefully uh that's a bit
of a wiz through everything that my
teams do and hopefully that was of some
interest
and i'm happy to answer any questions
right okay yeah before questions i'd
just like to say a huge thank you to
richard for that very informative
presentation covering the many aspects
of the private housing um
work that he and his team deal with and
i'd like to thank him also for the
excellent work that he and his team do
so thank you very much richard
thank you very much richard and jill uh
questions please well lots of hands up
there
i don't think i'll just first have my
hand up i've got a great long list so
i'll i'll just go for i'm from central
harbor and i've got a colleague here
from east cliffs so obviously we're
really interested in the selective
licensing can you just say a bit more
about what the
the
pluses and minuses are maybe of a
selective licensing scheme from the
council's point of view
yeah sure um
it depends on your viewpoint um
if you're a landlord or a tenant uh you
know
so
you know landlords obviously generally
not overly keen
because
licenses do come with a fee because it
is supposed to be self
funding so
so they have to pay for a license to be
subject to more regulation
which you know on the face of it um
might not seem great but what i always
say is that
you know if we're sinking a lot of
effort into an area to try and improve
it uh for everyone and the community
everything inevitably values are going
to go up and and
you probably seen the news quite
recently
about margate so
obviously
selective licensing may only be a small
element of that but certainly um you
know we have done a huge amount as you
can see over the last uh 10 years to try
and improve it so you know one assumes
uh that those people that paid 600 pound
a couple of times for a license have
probably got
greater uh uh in terms of capital asset
uh growth
um
what was really interesting when we did
the council because you have to consult
for each scheme the first scheme
i think um
the tenant or resident support was about
60 something percent and landlord
support was 15
second time round
residents went from 60 something percent
to 80 something percent and landlord
support went from about 15 to 26.9
so you can see we did turn the view of
some some of those landlords um and so i
think more
uh how can we say more strategic thing
thinking landlords
probably think it might not be a bad
thing that although they don't
particularly like paying the fee
um
uh
yeah i i i think yeah there's always
going to be some landlords that just can
absolutely
not be happy with that
policy
we were subject to a judicial review on
our first one which we ultimately won
um
yeah hopefully that's not some of that
question
council curry please
thank you chair and thank you richard
for your presentation and thanks to your
team and all the work you do
my question is is um i suppose um
regarding landlords as well
and uh it would be at fault under the
remit of the um housing improvements um
team
we've seen a worrying trend where
landlords are asked to do work
improvements
and sometimes because maybe they can't
afford to or they don't want to
they end up handing out section 21s to
their tenants
and we're getting a lot of casework at
the moment from tenants that are being
forced out of homes under a section 21
where the the landlord really has
decided not to do improvements i just
wondered is there any way that we can do
more to encourage
landlords to to do this work to prevent
them from handing out section 21s
because a lot of these people
as we know they they're paying as an
example 550 pounds for a two-bedroom the
landlord knows that they can now get 750
800 and and sometimes this is the reason
they're doing this
and some of these tenants end up having
to move out of the area i know it's a
difficult situation but just wondered if
there was any any more that we could do
and maybe your team could do to
to help this thank you
so there's a couple of things to mention
on that point um
first
well
in terms of the principle you're
absolutely right
you know a landlord at the moment can
issue a section 21 notice a no-fault
eviction
and he can do it for any reason and not
give a reason
um and that is completely lawful at the
moment so yes you know we see it on a
you know a regular basis that someone
makes a complaint
um
and then subsequently you know they're
served for section 21 notice
there is a small element of law that is
helpful but
not that helpful
if
the local authority serves an
improvement notice
there is a ban on evictions for six
months
however
before you can serve an improvement
notice you have
to notify the landlord that you're going
to do an hhs rs inspection
because that's a lawful thing we can't
just go along inspect it and then serve
a notice and then bang they've got six
months protection
we have to notify the landlord because
that is um
very important because if you don't then
everything you do subsequently falls
because you haven't done it legally
correct so the landlord has to get
notified at an early point and if he
decides he's going to make that decision
um
and you know it will it will always take
us
a
bit of time to get an improvement now
because they're quite complex
pieces of legal paperwork so it you know
might take a few weeks to get that that
done
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel
in as much as the government have
absolutely
confirmed that they are pushing on with
the ban
on section 21 notices
so um
uh so
in the not too distant future
um it's almost certain that um such
eviction processes will not happen
there will be some exemptions
like if you want to sell the property or
something like that but generally
speaking
there won't be a ban that they won't be
able to just on a whim
uh of each victory or tenant so that is
uh that is um um
certainly something that the government
has uh reinforced recently
thank you
councillor king
thank you that was really interesting
presentation
i just wondered if you could give a few
examples you said at the beginning of
the presentation about this sort of
three levels of responses um and
you know the
complaints wrote was the longest time
what sort of things would come under
that
category
so
um perhaps just whizz through them all
you may probably be uh probably helpful
so the the top one the high priority
would normally be things like there's a
there's a electric cable waving around
that's live and there's kids in the
house or uh there's no water uh which
has happened just recently uh for
another case so you've got no water or
something really dangerous or it's in
dangerous structural collapse or
anything like that then we'll get there
really quickly we say two days
you know but usually if we get a high
priority we're there straight away as
soon as possible
priority is
for things that we think shouldn't
wait too long and one of the main things
that comes under our priority one is no
hot water and heating
which is a very common complaint that we
have um boiler's broken and perhaps the
landlord's not keen on fixing it
and of course particularly this time of
year especially if there's vulnerable
people in the household you've got no
heating
no hot water inability to wash so
again right while we say
10 10 days
we tend to get to them pretty quickly as
well
things that um would probably come onto
the to the main bulk of the rotor where
things people have to wait their turn
because ultimately it's only fair that
you know as people come to us that we
see them in in turn
uh could be things like um
um
a little bit of damper mould here you
know maybe there's a bit you know in one
of the rooms it's not great but it's not
immediately going to be any serious risk
but something needs to be resolved
[Music]
um of course when we get complaints in
writing we're often not quite sure the
severity uh
you know
of the situation maybe the windows are
not you know a bit drafty or rattly or
not quite right or not quite opening
properly um
obviously if we thought it was a
an entry by intruder type hazard then
we'd be there quicker
um
[Music]
but we i would say
most of it goes on the voter to make
sure we see people as quickly as
possible in the summer it tends to
get to about
two weeks maybe a bit less
but we have to factor in the time that
we have to give landlord adequate notice
of the inspection to give them
opportunity to arrange to be there so
um so we send out letters and everything
so that you know if even if you do the
quickest situation it's probably going
to be a week but we in the summers two
weeks
um
you know
like any team at the council sometimes
we have staff shortages you know and
when the winter comes along you know the
damper mould suddenly gets a lot worse
and complaints start jumping
uh so yeah it can
we've never breached our service
standard of 10
10 weeks i think at the current time
it's uh i think it's somewhere but it's
about five weeks at the moment
yeah
thank you um just you said uh
cliftonville west was the fourth most
deprived nationally but had got better
recently where is it now do you know
offhand
i think it's a hundred and something if
i remember rightly yes thank you
excellent counselor
thanks chad can i ask two questions or
has that been greedy
thanks richard if your presentation is
really useful as always um you're saying
about your cold homes team
so you've got the funding till march
what happens after that is there more
funding available from central
government
and then um
yes probably best by that time my memory
is terrible right
yeah so there's no more money at the
moment uh from central government um
however
the main
thrust of what we need to do and the
work that we need to do to get to where
we are has been done because we've we've
managed to get um what we've done is we
seconded one of our
excellent officers to be a senior um and
then we brought in a domestic energy uh
assessor who's probably qualified and
can really give advice on how to improve
um the issues that have been raised
and then we have a
fabulous administrative assistant who
has just been absolutely brilliant
and between them all they have
managed to crack out all the compliance
notices that we could possibly do there
are no more that we could do at this
present time
um
and
ultimately we'll have the penalty
notices out shortly
um now there is a slight issue in the
law and hence the reason for the
consultation by the government is that
you can only financial penalty them up
to the point of five thousand pounds per
tenancy
so once you've reached the five thousand
pounds
then our hands are tired
uh but what we what we will do is issue
a penalty to everyone um
that fails to comply the regulations i
mean if it overruns a bit we will manage
that we'll manage that within existing
resources
and then
of course it'll come for the debt
recovery
procedures if if the payment's not
forthcoming
let's say
we talked about selective licensing in
margate and then maybe bring it into
ramsgate which would be great
so it seems like what's happening going
to happen what's the long-term plan
because you're saying the licenses are
going to expire in four years time
for most of the
landlords so what will happen then what
what's the long-term plan thanks
so um
there is um
the size of the schemes that we've done
before were um they're at the maximum
before you need secretary of state of
approval
um
so
what we're potentially looking at is
something that would have to go to
government and government have been um
wouldn't be wrong for me to say i've
taken quite a long time to uh to assess
uh such applications but they have
started coming through
um but before we move to that position
we're in a situation where we now need
to do another form of
stock modeling stop stop condition
survey of thanet because you know we
think these are the areas
but we really need an independent uh
document to say well actually
you know you need to look at this as
well but you know i suspect that it will
come back to where we think but um so
we're currently and i'm working with um
digital as well because we
have got a new uh
a product from a company that has uh
has got algorithms and all sorts of
stuff and they use huge amounts of data
and crunch all that and give and give us
a really good report so we're just
working on whether that data could be uh
be achieved can we actually provide that
data it's all anonymized so there's no
shouldn't be no
gdpr issues so
there's a meeting next week between
myself and digital to try and push that
on once we've got
that done and i'm told that could be
done within 12 weeks
then we're looking to
to get a consultant to help us
prepare
a new proposal and the consultant that
we're looking at at the present time is
a possibility is someone that has never
uh failed to achieve a designation for
their local authority and have been
working with the big authorities uh in
the country so
um
but they obviously can't really get
going until we have this survey report
which hopefully we can push on and then
after that
then we would have to go to a public
consultation
and that's a minimum of 10 weeks
and then we would assess
um the outcome of that
and then obviously it represented to to
council to determine what we should do
and then if we do decide that the
designation is the right thing for us to
do depending whether it's
you know
margate and ramsgate or one or the other
or wherever it may be uh then
we would
go to the secretary of state after
approval and then once they approve it
it'd be three months from there so
realistically we're probably thinking
a couple of years
but
what the positive thing in some ways is
is that
the landlords that were more reluctant
to license like i said earlier they are
going to be licensed probably for
another two three four so actually but
if something did come in in that area
they'd probably be still hanging on to
their old licensing
and and they would actually passport
onto that for the life of that existing
license
thank you chair and thank you richard
and jill for your presentation uh
playing devil's advocate um all this
legislation is for dealing with rogue
landlords
um there are good landlords out there
who have rogue tenants
so what policies and procedures have we
got to support them if any thank you
um so the remit within private sector
housing is obviously to make sure
housing is safe
um
uh but no i understand exactly what um
you're saying because you know we
routinely um
uh come across um
challenging situations um where the
tenant
has you know
made life unnecessarily difficult
perhaps
and but
all what we do is obviously take a view
in
on a case-by-case basis or what we
should do about it
so
for example if
a
tenant has complained to us we've gone
there we've written a report we've asked
we served the notice of something
and if we genuinely believe that um the
works haven't been completed completed
due to the abstraction
of the tenant then
then we wouldn't take any further action
for the time being because we only take
action when it's in the public interest
to do so
i'm i'm thinking more along the lines
that we can't make people live the way
you and i live but if you've got a
tenant that isn't living in a safe
manner and has caused the problems to
that dwelling and the landlord has got
to keep his property in a good order
what is there anything that you can do
to support the landlord to deal with
those tenants that don't look after
their properties because otherwise they
would be evicted because they're
detracting on the value of that of that
commercial interest
absolutely i mean of course we work
closely with our colleagues in the
market task force
you know you know if we see any issues
or where we think you know other
colleagues in other
professions or
you know or services can help out then
um
we certainly engage that as much as we
possibly can um you know we don't just
go in there focus with a silo thinking
we try to to to try to do everything we
possibly can but there are there are
some times when um
um you know
we can only do so much uh because we are
you know we have a a legal remit on
where we are
and
and you know
when it comes to
disrepair
if it is very serious
um
even though it perhaps may be the fault
of the tenant uh we may be under a duty
to take action against the landlord to
deal with that um because that is our
duty um and quite often um
we have tenants that have children
um you know it may be the um
say the parents
are causing
some issues but it's not their children
for example so we do have to be very
careful but there are certain
circumstances where we will not take
action because we're satisfied
that the tenants have not been there
there is only one
small area of legislation
specifically relating to hmos
where
if a tenant obstructs
the landlord in some things that we
could take action and threaten that
but it's only a very small area
that we can tackle for the most uh
properties that that power is not
available
did you say your question had already
been asked councillor again um yes uh
basic it was it's obviously the
selective license obviously works and
that can be shown by the stats um what
why does it come to end you know why why
doesn't that carry on i think a lot of
that was answered in your in your
previous question
yeah i mean there are various reasons i
mean um you know originally selective
licensing was introduced
um
as a five-year plan
uh and the government's you know only
allowed it to be uh
for five years because the uh the
thought process was you could deal with
it in five years
i think that is incredibly naive i
i think
if you get if you meet the test for
designation
and you have an area that has you know
become you know troubled for various
reasons
um
to think you could turn that around in
five years it is naive
so
i understand i believe uh because we i i
think we were
the first authority in the country to
designate when we were given those
powers
uh because in 2006 the powers come out
every designation had to be um
uh approved by the government and in
2010
it was given
that local authorities could designate
themselves and we did that uh we rushed
it well not rushed it but we we worked
hard uh but dedicated services to get
that to a point where we you know we
designated that in january 2011.
um
yeah so we we believe we're the first
local authority to back to back a scheme
have almost identical schemes back to
back such that when day one finished the
next one come along
we were threatened with judicial review
on the basis of you've done it once why
do you need it again
and
that didn't come to light because i
think we had a fairly robust
proposal
but
where we're at now is
that area has improved a lot but it
could still
do with
some further help and assistance but
there are other areas around that often
we've been
uh asked to look at that um that
potentially could benefit from selective
licensing so we so i think the general
thought processes was we'll take a step
back look at it a bit more holistically
see if we can
do something that perhaps affects a
wider region or wider areas where we can
help more people
you'll forgive me for drawing this to a
close now i'm sure
um
if you were to email a question to
richard you would receive an answer
fairly quickly i was also just wondering
whether um a similar presentation might
be given on one of the drop-in
evenings where a broader section of
councillors will be able to see
speak to bob about yes i just wondered
whether that might be something we could
do as well um but i i would like to
thank you very very much i'm sorry to
have uh
brought it to it to an end uh but um we
do unconscious that we have uh
adrian verrell here to present
as well so can i thank you very very
much on behalf of this panel for coming
and doing your presentation and
councillor jill bayford thank you very
much for coming as well and as his
customary we'll give you a moment just
to pack up and and leave if you'd like
to or you're very welcome to stay
listen to agent
but thank you very much and apologies
again members
okay
right
okay members uh thank you very much i'll
now call upon adrian verrell to
introduce his report on the birchington
neighborhood plan
i don't won't pretend to know what
regulation 16 consultation formal
response is but we're going to find out
thank you very much angel adrian
thank you
um yes members i'm just really
briefly introduced to report
regulation 16
i should start with that i guess is is
the fourth the kind of final formal
consultation before the examination into
the neighborhood plan takes place
so that consultation is running at the
moment it finishes on the 24th of
february
next thursday
uh beyond that um
this is a slightly strange situation for
those who've not been involved in
neighborhood plans probably most of you
it's prepared by a neighborhood plan
group or a parish council
and at different stages effectively the
the district council has to take on
responsibility for progressing certain
things through to the examination so
um
we are hosting the consultation uh at
the moment
um and after that consultation finished
we will collate
the comments that have been made the
examination is set up so it's not
exactly like a local plan examination
because
uh
it's an examiner rather than an
inspector but it doesn't make an awful
lot of difference
so we're working with burstington parish
council at the moment to appoint an
examiner to carry that out
this report is just about the comments
we are
recommending that this council makes to
that consultation
um
i know that sounds like we've been
making comments to ourselves but
actually we're making comments on the
neighborhood plan which will be given
to the examiner
so in the report
we've set out some recommended
comments
the summary of that is in paragraph
1.11
i should say that we're actually very
supportive
of the of the neighborhood plan a lot of
work has been done
by the parish council and their
neighbourhood planning group they've
gathered a lot of evidence
there's a lot of very sound stuff in
there so we're not making a huge amount
of comments as you can see from that
paragraph
and
those responses are set out in more
detail in the table at annex one so
we've i've we've
summarized them here
but there's a bit more detail in the
annex and i won't go through that in all
in detail but if members have got any
questions
i will happily answer them the one thing
i
would
point to
um
policy b4 in the bertington plan
talks about the local list and i know
probably some of you as councils will
have encountered the local assets list
important local listing as against the
national
listed buildings process
in
uh the neighborhood plan there is a
policy which talks about applying
certain policies to the local listed
properties and assets at the moment
there is a draft list that the parish
council neighborhood plan group and
others have put together that has to go
through certain stages
um
before it
sort of achieves more for more formal
status we're not suggesting they change
that policy
but obviously
it won't carry full weight until that
list
is kind of finally adopted
um
i'll leave it there i'm more than happy
to ask questions about the suggested
responses or about the neighborhood plan
process
thank you
thank you very much
members do you have any comments you'd
like to make
council fellows yeah thank you
i just want to reiterate a few comments
especially what's in annex one um a huge
amount of time has been
um spent on this uh notepad plan um
quite a dedicated group of people have
put it together they're volunteers
they've worked for six years putting
this neighborhood plan together
and it's a product of consultation
collaboration and research that um
uh produced a very professional document
which i've actually seen and i've been a
part of and and
i've solved bachelors counselor myself
so um
um as
the group knew i was a member of this
overview and screening they've just
wanted me to make a few comments to tdc
on their behalf
and also um answer um a few of the
queries that are in the annex one um
concerning policy b4 b8 and um
excuse me because i only got this late
today
and and policy b 21 as well so then what
they wanted to say was um obviously i
just reiterated that the neighborhood
plans products for six years
consultation collaboration and research
um there's been extensive community
engagement at each stage of the
development and the plan is a true
reflection of the community values and
expectations
and the tdc officers should be thanked
for their patient support and advice and
the fact there's been minimal comments
on the neighbor on the neighborhood plan
from officers at this stage illustrates
how beneficial the joint working has
been
so i would go back to what you were
saying about um policy b4 there was a
comment um are you saying that the the
about the list hasn't um been fully
generated they did say that they didn't
think that um
on that policy that that there's been
enough support from the td officers and
and they're quite concerned about the
lack of progress
on that which obviously going to create
less effectiveness of the national plan
policies so they're quite concerned that
that local list hasn't been uh generated
as yet so uh that's all i want to say at
the moment i mean we can talk about the
other policies
if anybody's got any concerns about them
but
thank you
thank you very much uh council fellows
and that uh
i wonder if i can turn to you very
quickly on party b 21 there on the annex
it the suggestion is delete the words to
the parish council
yeah that that's right um
because talent district council is the
local planning authority not the parish
council
in fact when you talk about local plan
policies inspectors often remove the
words to the district council
because their argument is that the
policy is for the decision maker whoever
that happens to be so that's the reason
for that
okay thank you very much thank you
council first so what they said about
policy b21 is that they believe the
policy is entirely consistent with the
national planning and policy framework
and the local plan uh it supports local
planning policy to deliver 30 affordable
housing and simply seeks to achieve
transparency where the local planning
authority deems that it's not viable for
a developer to deliver that requirement
i think that's been seen recently with
other planning applications as
well uh yeah i mean all i all i'd say to
that i understand um parish council's
concern but ultimately the decision
about the level of affordable housing
the viability study is a matter for
this council
obviously if the parish council make
comments at application stage the case
officer
and the planning committee can take
those comments into account but it's not
a decision to be made by the parish
council that's it's a it's a technical
thing
not to say the parish council can't have
a view or make their comments known or
make their views known but ultimately
the decision is for the district council
thank you which is what we are today yes
um thank you very much councillor boyd
please
thank you chair um
i wonder if you could just expand a bit
more about i mean i'm not an expert on
planning and i won't ever pretend to be
um but could you explain a bit more
about the green wedge policy and whether
there might be a slight contradiction
with our own policy and that that should
be something we should look into as it
could open up the floor for other
neighborhood plans to potentially come
up with their own green wedge um
policies thank you
uh yes i mean it's understandable that
parish council and others
wanting to protect particularly
important green spaces i understand that
uh degree and a lot of these areas if
it's outside the urban area they're
protected by general countryside
policies anyway because the way we
phrase our policies
is that unless it's something that we've
allocated in the local plan it shouldn't
come forward unless a specific
justification for it so
whilst i understand that sort of general
concern about protecting important areas
the green wedges have a very particular
role there is a green wedge between
burchington and westgate for example
it's about preventing those two
settlements coalescing and there's
another one between broadstairs and
margate and broadstairs and ramsgate and
it's really about trying to stop
the sort of more urban areas if you'd
like coalescing and closing up those
gaps
our view is that that doesn't really
apply in this case it obviously does
between burtington and westgate on that
side
but really to the other side to the
south and beyond uh to the west
you're not really talking about closing
out gaps between
urban areas and such so
uh and our concern is that
we we've been very successful with the
green wedge policies in the senate
we've been able to defend those
continuously through several local
planned cycles
and appeal generally and obviously we
don't want that policy to become
undermined
by trying to apply it to areas it
doesn't really apply to so that's that's
the reason for that
thank you
thank you very much
counselor
thank you uh churn thank you adrian um
can i just ask a question about process
rather than about this specific plan so
the fan district council has made
comments
um birchington parish council or the
people who've written the neighborhood
plan want to respond to those
does all of that then go to the examiner
as is that they're not going to change
that plan now on the basis of what
you've said
that that the plan is how it is and then
all of that with your comments goes to
the examiner and then is is considered
on that basis is that is that right
it's a bit it's a bit like we have a
similar stage called regulation 19 which
is basically the same sort of formal
consultation so we publish that we get
loads of comments back we don't change
the plan at that stage it's for the
inspectors
to sort of look at the different
position
and it's the same here really
yeah and then the examiner will
will the examiner then recommend we'll
say yes what thank you street council
said on this this and this that needs to
happen but on this then we're happy with
how it is anyway or whatever that that
that's the kind of feedback that the
examiner will give that's right uh the
ins the examiner will give
recommendations
uh both to us i think and to the parish
council to say
you know in my view the plan shouldn't
be amended on this particular case but
should be amended on these yeah
check to see if councillor piper has a
question before
before you go home
i'm going to get filmed i'm going to get
some time
remember any more questions or comments
you'd like to make um looking at the
options before us if i start with number
three uh number three option is the
council does not respond to the
regulation 16 consultation i think we're
probably all agreed that that would not
be a good idea
which takes us to uh options one and two
that the comments in annex one of this
report are agreed to be submitted as the
council's formal response to regulation
16 consultation
and option 2
that these comments are amended before
being submitted to the council's formal
response to regulation 16
consultation
i haven't seen any suggestions or heard
any suggestions for
amending so does that leave us with
option one
that the comments in annex one of this
report are agreed to be submitted as the
council's formal response
to the regulation 16 consultation
if that's the case can i have a proposal
please
counselor tomlinson thank you very much
and a seconder
councillor piper thank you very much
do members agree
agree
thank you very much
uh moving on then
to the next
substantive item in our agenda
i'm not going to try and spin that
screen anymore
makes me eyes water
we've got the review of the overview and
scrutiny work program
that i think most of us
are
familiar with
we have
the
next cabinet member
presentation is on information
communication
and technology uh this sums stems from a
request
um that i
asked uh charles hungway to put two
cabinets for us on how we've been
responding for the uh the need for
improving information and communications
and so on so we look forward to that in
march in april
um i've asked if we can have the climate
emergency decoration that we made can we
have an update about how that is going
uh one particular question i have but
we'll take as many questions as are
available at that time if members wish
to bring them is the business of
printing
yes no doubt the council's printing has
gone down significantly but how many of
us are doing a lot of printing at home
which has shifted the footprint from
this building
and scattered it around around sanity
but that's just one area but that was an
area i thought we might like an update
on to see how that's going um in july
which is the next available meeting for
a presentation
i've asked the leader
to come and talk to us about the
effectiveness or not
of the cabinet advisory group system
that's been developed to see whether
they are well attended and whether they
are actually helping the leader in the
way uh she
uh puts together concerns of members and
members of the public and the way in
which uh the council
uh is operating so those those three are
due between now and july
can i encourage you please if you've got
any other
uh particular areas you'd like a
presentation on uh please either uh
contact me uh if you wish or
charles and copy me in so i know what's
what's being asked but does anybody have
anything this evening that they would
like me to put onto this list
to communicate to charles would you like
to sort of take it back and have a we
think
but we've got some interesting subjects
coming up and as we've seen this evening
they can be
very very
informative
um i have had a request from a member of
ramsgate town council
that we set up
uh
a subcommittee or a working party
to monitor progress
on
the
future high street scheme ramsgate the
heritage
high street scheme at ramsgate and the
welcome back
fund
because the request came to me that
would the committee
set up something to look at these things
what i uh propose to do and i hope you
won't mind is i'm going to point that
counsellor towards the
link
which will show the videos we were due
to be shown
the other day but we're not able to see
but they are available to have a look at
and then perhaps
when
that counselor has had an opportunity to
see those and see what's happening with
this funding and so on we can then
revisit the subject so i haven't
forgotten about the request uh notably
if there were to have a review on that
kind of activity the earliest uh
opportunity would be august
and we will find out whether or not it's
a suitable subject for a working group
or whether it's more keeping people
updated with with progress that's being
made but since i received the email i
thought i should bring it to you there
has been requests cancer thompson
uh thank you chair uh thank you for that
um
it would be wrong for me and we missed
to say i'd like to think because
a lot of us over here
are also being asked to say where is
this money going
obviously it's in our
online newspaper and everything else and
answered by so many people
but i think what you've come out with
here um
for ram skater
i don't i don't think margaret should be
left off
but yeah if that's
there's lots
sorry just to say there is a lot of
information out there already on these
funding schemes viral websites however
we don't have a problem as officers
coming along
in a sensible time period giving you an
update against the fund that's been
allocated the funds have been allocated
and how they've been spent what they've
been spending against got no problem
doing that i think it's better as a
presentation like that rather than a
working group but you know that's for
that's for you to you to decide but no
problem
okay thank you very much thank you very
much for that um
council fellows did you did you want to
give us any update
on the work of the coastal waste review
working party thus far i'd love to chair
such a such an interesting subject yeah
so i i have here hot off the press an
initial draft it's very drafty it's
so it's initial draft and we're going to
call a meeting within the next couple of
weeks where we'll sit around the working
group sits around myself counselor
austin councillor king councillor attica
and councillor um thomason um where we
will add or take out whatever it is
it's quite a lot in there um
and we'll present it at the next
overview and scrutiny which i think is
the 15th of march
and if it's
okay then then it'll be presented to
cabinet in april
hopefully then
all the recommendations will take on
board but
we'll see
thank you very much indeed thank you for
the work that you're doing on that
behind the scenes i'm sure we'll be
very pleased to see it when it comes out
hopefully
in uh in in march
uh the forward plan and exempt cabinet
report list do any members have any
comments they wish to make
on that list
okay thank you um in that case that
concludes the business for the meeting
this evening it's 8 25
um the live streaming of this meeting
will now end thank you all for your
attendance and participation in what we
do and thank you to all the officers for
coming
and supporting us in the way that you do